named Adam and math battle Pam you
remember that [ __ ] poppy s son dirty
pop they even called it dirty pop that's
how disrespectful was there to pop one
stood on the back and danced and Vance
Vance in round em up when it did that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was kind of tight though
right Justin Timberlake I'm sick all
these people [ __ ] touching on my
shoulder I'm sick of people asking for
[ __ ] pictures prayer during a pop
we're all the same guy
Brianna look at us put our faces on each
other we got the same haircut except for
that weird one Chris Kirkpatrick why the
thunk
his head look like a [ __ ] purple
dirty pop JC Chasez or whatever even
though his last name should be Chavez
his last name is Charles ass that's
[ __ ] ridiculous
almost as ridiculous as the blond
tarantula on his head during a pop lance
bass of course is gay it was never in
question
his eyes are too blue eggs do good at
dancing Joey Fatone it's so weird that
he is definitely the one that weighs the
most in his last name is fat one
Joey Fatone
last name is fat one and he's the fat
one
I mean what what kind of cruel
joke was that oh dude was that the song
where Justin Timberlake said I'm tired
of singing and then and then did like
big dude in the history of music there
has never been alert
then when Justin Timberlake says man I'm
tired of singing and then just [ __ ]
makes farting noises god damn that's
awesome you know what the most
illis [ __ ] moment of music was in the
world was when in that [ __ ] song with
Pharrell and Justin Timberlake when he
says to nobody hold my jacket that is so
ill it's unreal that's so ill when that
happened I actually think nobody
realized it but we skipped a year hold
my jacket what who what for no reason
just felt so dope and this song we
started was a chunk sugars yung-chun
sugars are doing to him soon sugars
young and he just goes oh my jacket how
how dope is that that's [ __ ] James
Bond in real life [ __ ]